where we have to view everything through
the lens of this black and white i got
to tell you yesterday a guy
was asking me a question he says hey pat
can you can you go on twitter please my
account and he says can you tell me what
you don't like about capitalism tell me
what you don't like because you're so
much about capitalism can you say
something you don't like about capitals
okay right so that's a fair question so
i responded back to the guy and i
tweeted and i actually answered them
here's what i said okay my answer was
keep going down keep going down keep
going down keep going down down down
there it is okay click on that tweet
because there's a part two and a part
three click on the top no no not
tyler we got to teach you what to click
on right there that's right there okay
good all right so
i said he asked me a question i'm a big
valuetainer from india and i have a
question if there's just one thing you
would change about kaplan's what would
it be i said this is what i would change
about capitalism number one eliminate
all lobbyists
and special interest group this is how
big companies like pfizer bully small
companies capitalism by itself is good
until politicians who need campaign
money to get re-elected get desperate
they're often for sale right number two
is create a flat tax that puts everybody
in same camp et cetera et cetera stay on
the first one right there stay right
there that's cronyism that's not
capitalism well you're right it is
cronyism but what pfizer what what
pfizer is doing today
pfizer is getting the fda correct that
they've probably bought to say hey
can you go out there and make sure you
delay the number of losses till 2076 who
the hell is going to give a crap about
anything to do with covet 55 years from
let me make my point you'll go in 55
years from now we'll be including 75. so
then yesterday yesterday yesterday
some people said yeah
yesterday some people also said bezos
just gave a hundred million dollars to
obama's foundation okay so on the back
end folks are saying well maybe
those issues that you know bezos and
amazon was facing
uh obama's gonna make a phone call to
biden to get a favor yeah it's it's
things like this where you lose trust
because manipulation takes place at the
highest level
you're a dummy if you don't sit there
and say 2000. you know what a guy just
said something right now the answer was
a follow-on here's what the guy said i
want to give him credit because the
answer was a great answer he says he
says you want to wait till 2076 to
uh release all the data guess what i'm
going to wait till 2076 to take the
vaccine so that's what i'm going to do
by the way
is it reasonable is it reasonable i
think it's reasonable fair yeah i think
it's reasonable because i want to get
more data before i take it right if
you're if you're a data person this
gives more red flags for somebody not to
take supports or cause not take a
vaccine and you know back to this you
know we're looking at the fda is the fda
here to protect the consumer or here to
protect the government and based on what
we're saying here that's a governing
entity
uh not you know that's a government
entity that's going to not protect
i agree with the overall premise all
right but i just and this might be
semantics and this might be a
nonsensical word argument but what is
described there and that happens all the
time cronyism that's actually not
capitalism what that is is corporatism
that's where the government picks
winners in certain you know functions
right where you give pfizer a billion
dollar grant now a small company you
can't come up with compete with that but
here's the here's the thing to me that's
closer to socialism than it is there's
no question of course it is but it is an
extension of capitalism because the
capitalists are using this
uh that's available to them this usage
they're using this do you think cronyism
and corporatism is an inevitable end of
capitalism
if the laws are the way they are right
now yes for example as much as i love
this phone
as much as i love this phone if you go a
little lower i said uh number three more
competition for business that haven't
had for many years apple needs more
competition it concerns me that there's
not really a second competitor in
smartphones in the us right now tesla
was the best thing that happened to us
consumers they woke up the automobile
industry to improve bottling needs
competition coke and pepsi on ninety
percent of market i leave it there the
point is
look at this this is a concern apple
apple is this apple i don't know if this
is this ipad or no
apple apple apple apple apple apple this
is not good this is not so that's
absolutely that is a form of what makes
capitalism you know end up going in this
direction so yeah i don't think these
guys should be taking money from these
guys because the more why would an fda
say yes
go behind closed doors saying how much
money
you not
too far in that available
uh
this is this is not a new thing this has
been going on for quite some time look
again i'm at harvard i'm at an opm
program owner president management this
is a three-week program where you go and
stay there with other ceos and
entrepreneurs one guy says i own
majority of the market in brazil what
the hell do i do there's this new guy
that's coming out that's kicking my ass
the other guy from another central
american country comes out and says very
easy what governor is running for
campaign for reelection give him 500 000
and tell him you'll give another half a
million dollars if he makes it
impossible for the other guy to compete
with you believe me this is what we do
all the time
this is in the open discussion
it's like a regular talk this is what
country and and this was brazil i don't
remember the other guy where he was that
but the guy the guy that's working at
the front the teacher who was like the
moderator is like well well well you
can't really do something like because
like no you can't that's right
you can do this it reminds me of rodney
dangerfield in that in that old uh back
to school where he goes back to school
and he's sitting there and they're
learning business and he keeps scoffing
they're like you think you know
something about business he goes yeah
you didn't even tell you throwing any
bribes for the teamsters they're gonna
shut the union down the first day unless
you grease the pipes and he does this
whole thing it's a great scene but when
you talk about when people travel india
one of the classic movies of all time
when people talk about the quote-unquote
illuminati and this like crazy cabals
and stuff like that that's what they're
talking about they're talking about the
bilderbergs and and the world economic
forum where all these incredibly
powerful people and all these incredibly
powerful influential positions get
together and they make these back room
deals like that we don't have access to
that we don't have access to to that
sort of power by the way by the way i
don't mind it if it happens in free
market i mind it if you lean on the
government for example this lady that
they're talking about making the
treasury for uh biden right what's
what's her name tyler uh uh uh
uh um say that again omar have a hard
time saying her name omarava omarava
right so a video circulates among what
she just recently said so she's at the
court ted cruz has called on a rod have
you guys seen this back in fourth or
have you seen ted cruz and her going
back and forth or no have you seen it
have you had a chance to see this or not
okay if it's c-span it's worthy of
seeing this
uh if it's c-span it's worthy of seeing
this take a look at it and see if it's
out there or not so this lady flat out
says you said omarava oh how
wants to eliminate the fed i said no way
let me hear this okay good for you joe
and it was like yeah eliminate the fed
and all private banking right now oh my
robot it's like omarosa
you guys have you guys actually seen
this or not on c-span okay
oh my
oh man if it's not on c-span we
obviously cannot watch it because of uh
uh what happens okay i don't know if
it's there or not anyways he calls her
out she used to be uh she's born and
raised in russia full-on communist okay
and she's coming in and she says well
yeah i used to be a communist says you
don't stay as a member you kind of grow
out of being a communist that's her
answer she just kind of nonchalant talks
about it play the video i just sent you
by the way tyler the one i uh by the way
obama said the same thing in his book he
did but watch this just let's not
interrupt let her say what she says in
an interview press play here's what she
has to say
this would be actually
the full transition in other words there
will be no more private uh bank deposit
accounts and all of the deposit accounts
will be held directly at the fed
and there are very interesting
implications uh from that thought
experiment for example with uh the much
more direct and proactive tools of
monetary policy like helicopter money
which is uh
you know considered radical primarily
because uh economists really do not know
how to manage the issue of what will
happen
in the inflationary environment when the
central bank needs to contract the
supply of money how is it
politically feasible for the central
bank to effectively take money away from
uh people's account
people's accounts let me play the last
10 seconds one more time folks i want
you to listen to this one more time this
is who may end up getting elected well
listen press play yeah stop everything
you're doing contract the supply of
money how is it
politically feasible for the central
bank to effectively take money away from
uh people's
ouch people's accounts that's her word
naturally what she's saying
so you asked the question you said
you know how these guys get together the
powerful people behind closed doors and
their broker deals all that stuff i
don't mind that as long as the
government's not involved i have zero
problem with that because if i can do a
better job persuading him to broker the
deal with me versus him i'm good because
it's forced
because because i can screw it up with
him well he'll go with him but if i'm
dealing with the government if i screwed
up with him
there is no there's no choice no so
these guys when they're thinking central
back the reagan the the audience sees
this like if you said this to the
because the government became a
competitor the government became a
competitor you know that's just
communism a lot of people
that's just comments of course that is
so again the concept goes back to go to
dmv ask for good service see what they
give you
what's the alternative there's not
another dmv there is not another dmv so
if we no longer have b of a chase ice to
bank would be of a guess what i did i
went to wamu obama was crushing it i've
been with woman chase for god knows how
many years now if wamu doesn't take care
you've got to wells fargo while scar
doesn't you got this you got that so we
switched one of our business banks for
uh the company because the new bank was
better for us and the other bank you
know how much money they lost in
deposits 100 million dollars of deposits
they lost but if i don't have that
choice where i can only go to the
central bank you are screwed
it's worse than that even because think
about what we just talked about they're
regulating a medicine now they have
access to your funding
and they say unless you get what we want
you unless you put what we want in your
body we're not going to give you access
to your money yeah well that's why biden
wanted to expand the irs enforcement to
make sure that anything that you
bring in over 600 is monitored so
therefore if you're not paying taxes on
it they can come after you say hey we
saw that you have a bunch of deposits
600 bucks 700 bucks 800 bucks you never
file tax on it because you're a waiter
because you work on tips but you're a
cash money guy you have a you have a you
sell a lot in the corner and you have
your work running cash bill you're
depositing over 6 700 bucks a day now
you have to file taxes on it and they're
forcing that regulation appropriately
we're never going to raise taxes on on
the middle class no no no no no no but
on that they realized that three
trillion dollar plan was gonna pay and
that was something that they were
proposing and but they realized that it
was a logistical nightmare and the banks
are like dude we're not trying to
monitor every six hundred dollars and
they raised obviously ten thousand
dollars is the traditional number for
these types of things but
it just goes to show that
sometimes bad ideas can sort of
percolate and if there's not people
being like
what's happening what's going on here
you know they could somehow get
implemented so someone like this that
clearly we're like what's this lady's
deal what's this
taking money from people's account what
is this idea going on here if there's
not backlash or it's not people raising
their hands like literally verbally
protesting
someone like this can come that's a
great point like jazlane maxwell trial
is going on right now and nobody even
knows
everybody knows everything that's
happening with the kyle written house
child every second of everything you
know and there was some good theater
there those two prosecutors were
all-time morons with you know what they
try is your account four doors more
sir yeah i'm a teenager what's
what of it bro i'm a teenager with a
social media account like it was it was
a remarkably bad job that they did but
gizlane maxwell if everybody knows who
she's laying max was she was the number
the number two the number two you know
she was the gopher man and
we all we all remember what jeffrey
epstein had his hands in and all of
those people that he was
is that on the news at all where's the
coverage
what type of social engineering is going
on what type of manipulation is going on
that we don't know that they're trying
to centralize our money underneath them
they're trying to control our medicine
they're trying to control our
information pat just read an article
before where they slipped in propaganda
in an article you know which is safe and
it's safe and available guys like okay
thanks buddy at what point are we like
gonna as people stand up and like be
like all right enough's enough so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]